When you first fall in love, it’s a whirlwind
of crazy emotions and obsession and anxiety.
And then eventually it’s not.
So did you fall out of love or did it turn
into something new?
Hey there loved ones, Julian here for DNews.
If you’ve ever fallen in love, you know
it does all sorts of odd things to you.
Your palms get sweaty, knees weak, arms are
heavy, you tell her you can cook but you can
only make spaghetti.
At first it’s totally exhilarating, then
over time you get more comfortable but no
less in love.
What’s changed inside your brain?
Why does young love feel different than old
love?
Scientists have wondered the same thing, and
they’ve used fMRI machines to peer into
people’s brains and find out what’s happening
when you first tumble head over heels for
someone.
It turns out love feels so good because it
makes two regions of your brain light up:
the caudate nucleus, and the ventral tegmental
area.
Both these regions are associated with reward
and pleasure because they’re rich in the
dopamine.
But dopamine isn’t the only neurotransmitter
giving you that distinct, new-love feel.
Oxytocin and vasopressin are mixed into that
mental cocktail too.
Oxytocin is released after sex or with skin-to-skin
contact and produces feelings of contentment
and security, bringing couples closer together.
Vasopressin is also associated with long-term
bonding.
New love doesn’t just amplify neurotransmitters,
it reduces some too.
When you’re in that phase, your body releases
the hormone cortisol, also known as the stress
hormone.
As cortisol levels rise in the body, serotonin
levels in the brain go down.
As a neurotransmitter, serotonin helps relay
messages from one area of the brain to another,
and Harvard Medical School’s Richard Schwartz
says its depletion causes those intrusive,
maddening thoughts you have when you’re
in the early stages of love.
It’s what causes infatuation and obsession.
And finally, new love can shut down some neural
pathways altogether, particularly the one
that connects the nucleus accumbens to the
amygdala.
That pathway is associated with fear and social
judgment, and helps us make critical assessments
of people.
Ever fallen in love with someone who was objectively
terrible, and then later wondered why you
didn’t see it?
Now you know why.
Over time, some of these chemical levels change.
Your body stops pumping out cortisol and your
serotonin levels come back up.
That’s why that anxiety goes away and you
stop worrying about how you look or if you’re
coming off as too needy.
And you actually become less needy because
the higher levels of serotonin make you less
obsessive.
Your brain and body are less stressed and
you stop feeling that manic craving for your
romantic partner.
But that doesn’t mean you can’t be madly
in love with someone, even after decades.
Since oxytocin levels are boosted after sex,
those can be brought back up at any time with
a roll in the hay.
Other neurotransmitter levels can remain constant.
A 2011 study by Stony Brook University compared
the brain activity of couples who had just
fallen in love to couples that had been married
for 21 years on average.
Those dopamine centers in the brain associated
with reward and pleasure were just as rich
in the older couples as the new ones.
So over time, they had gotten more comfortable
but still felt just as happy.
We can’t do DNews episodes without our sponsors.
Thanks to Kay Jewelers for sponsoring this
episode.
For 100 years, every kiss begins with K.
You may not be in a relationship right now
but still want to feel some of that touchy-feely
goodness.
So can you make someone fall in love with
you?
Find out here.
Which do you prefer, intense romance or long
term love?
Let us know in the comments, sub scribe for
more and I'll see you next time on DNews.